family where are you at moment and
what's been going on in the last 24 48
hours view I'm in Denver Colorado and I
came here to attend the yearly March
meeting of the American Physical Society
which is every year the largest
gathering of physicists in the world but
that hasn't quite gone to plan this year
tell me what's been happening so the the
American Physical Society sent out an
email on Saturday night it was about
8:00 p.m. on the East Coast saying that
the meeting was being called off and the
reason was there were increased concerns
about the spread of the corona virus
epidemic the news arrived in people's
inboxes only 36 hours before the meeting
was due to start on Monday morning and
so close to it a lot of people including
yourself had actually already travelled
to get to the meeting and are now in
Denver yes so the the kate care be the
CEO of the society said that they
estimated several hundred participants
we're already in town perhaps close to a
thousand so tell me what are the
scientists are still in Denver doing
there are people that are trying to sort
of make the best of this not ideal
situation yes some of the people who
ended up sort of stranded in Denver
decided to have informal gatherings and
and what people call unconferences which
means you get together and you without
any prearranged schedule and you you
know whoever wants to give a talk gives
a talk and at the same time there's
people who are going to record their own
talks as videos and upload them on
YouTube or other platforms and and the
the American faces physical society
itself is going to provide a platform
for you know would be participants in
the conference some groups of physicists
went further and they they basically
tried to recreate the schedule of
conference as a series of webinars so
they they set up an online spreadsheet
where people could post links to their
live talks that will happen at the same
time that they were supposed to give the
talks in them there it's a really
interesting sort of exercise in how to
make the best of a difficult situation
are people feeling quite positive that
you've been speaking to or confused you
know what's the feeling among the
physicists that you have found that are
still in Denver
I mean people where you know they were
inconvenienced and some were worried
especially students who maybe didn't
have a lot of experience with meetings
were worried you know how how am I going
to get my reimbursement which is tied to
me giving a talk I think generally
speaking you know people people realize
that the situation is escalating it's
getting serious and that a lot of
participants were going to come from
countries that were now hotspots of the
epidemic we've had people talking about
trying to discourage people from shaking
hands for example conferences but this
is quite a big step that's been taken
and and really done at the 11th hour yes
and it's probably only the first one of
many such cancellations there's already
reports that a number of meetings in the
next few months are being cancelled not
only in physics in a lot of different
fields the the thing that prompted the
the 10 precipitated the situation with
the March meeting of the APS was that
the u.s. Center for Disease Control and
Prevention on Saturday kind of upgraded
its its travel warning for to countries
that that are major contributors to to
the physics meeting that's South Korea
and Italy and what does this mean for
the conference is that other plans to
reschedule it for a different time or is
it just cancelled and that's it for this
year I don't know yet I think it's very
early to say I think a lot of it will
depend on
the community reacts and whether they
feel that you know these all these
various informal ways of communicating
where were you know satisfactory or not
and what does this mean for you you're a
physics reporter who's gone to report in
a conference that doesn't exist anymore
what does your next week look like now
so I changed my flight I'm going to fly
back on Wednesday originally I was going
to fly stay in town until Sunday and for
me it's you know it's it's a missed
opportunity to catch up with a lot of
people to learn about a lot of new ideas
and new experiments and so on but such
is life